or you get to spend the day with me what
you choosing $11,000 1,000 spend the
next day with
you you a smart that was smooth that was
smooth that's right have $5,000 or one
night with me you know what I like you
could get uh like I don't know what cost
but I'm I don't I think you could get a
comparable probably $5,000 right now
$5,000 what du
I mean that's like expected maybe maybe
I just you know maybe I just never had
it like that but I just would never
expect I mean five Grand's a good chunk
of change night with
me
uh
[Music]
damn even look too L what up guys
welcome to the just cly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell like the video on your
way in and get yourself a wom and
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I am going
to be reacting to when women get
rejected and Men stop sing let's go or
you get to spend the day with me which
you choosing $11,000 1,000 in the next
day with
you you're a smart that was smooth that
was smooth that's right have $5,000 or
one night with me I mean this is like an
average chick you know what I like you
could get uh like I don't know what
hookers cost but I'm I don't I think you
could get a
comparable probably $5,000 right now
$5,000 uh
$5,000 what du $5,000 I mean that's like
expected maybe maybe I just you know
maybe I just never had it like that but
I just would never expect I mean five
Grand's a good chunk of change night
with
me
[Music]
damn he L you like he got there in the
end but he took way too long answering
that she's got an only fan she's for the
fans she's not for you I'll take a
dollar and go buy a pack of chewing gum
Adrian's deal breakers is someone who
doesn't have a j o yeah someone doesn't
have a job I don't have a job you don't
have a
job too slow I got a
[Music]
burrito you loyal like getting laid
probably not cuz it doesn't happen often
does it why why is the first thing you
say is about getting late is that the
most valuable thing you offer a man is
what you can give him in bed clearly
that's what you think that's what you
just placed up here you're not getting
late so do you think it's a good thing a
man sleeping around with a bunch of
women that's not what I said you said
you're not getting that's what they do
oh you're you're this you're they're
like hyenas yeah because this is how you
act why are you so why you why you do
this with your time stay away from women
like this yeah stay away from me tell my
boyfriend that I've been with for three
years to stay away from me three years
in WoW put a ring on it that's really
tough yeah it's
probably send him for in it cat lady
know what your mouth me those cats are
kind of cute reminds me of like a person
from hooville because you like lip is
not there well I can't help that no no
you can't it's just like body shaming is
fine nerve you know what I mean do I
have to say it it's all about the weight
right goodness here come the comments do
you think guys prefer natural bodies or
bbl's bbl's bbl's BBL BBL BBL BBL bodies
for sure that fake [__] yeah I feel like
J Jones you know it's so interesting I
did it before and after of a woman it
was Trump's daughter um Molina and I
don't know if it was editing or if she
had work done but I did a before and
after and normally I'm anti-work um
getting like I I usually don't like the
way it looks but I actually thought it
looked okay with her and I pulled the
guys and I said like which do you prefer
everybody put before I almost think that
the beauty industry kind of makes the
women look more masculine minus the
cartoon BBL things those just look weird
most of us men when you commented under
this post 100% f
[Music]
the greatest of all
time oh
wow
yeah oh that's embarrassing
single yes but no what do you mean you
single but no um I'm in a situation sh
that just makes no [__] sense so what
does that mean
exactly oh I could tell you guys it
means the screw's going on but the
commitment is not there does that mean
you could dance with another guy I mean
he dances with other girls
so that's what I'm so then you mean you
single
then yeah so what is this whole
situationship generation I don't know I
want a relationship he's like oh we're
just having fun like I'm not ready for
commit
that mean he don't want you bro really
you think
so even though he calls me all the time
and everything that means he wants to
keep you around but at the same time he
wants to mess around with
you we're here to [__] [__] that was
honest you don't get that much anymore
somebody been Pander and just like s
that was
honest she's like a female s he's only
keeping her around and calling her when
he wants to get some he's not taking her
serious otherwise he wouldn't be seeing
other people and if she thinks she's
going to get a relation ship part of it
then she's delusional how much do you
want your man to make a year be honest I
just want him to pay my bills honestly
that's it okay and provide for our kids
don't be too picky I'm going to be too
picky till the day I die one minute
later you want dance okay you want
dance oh sorry it's okay
oh oh that was humbling for this chick
they'll never forget that you know the
key to a happy marriage is simple
communication so the next time your wife
is upset with you giving you the silent
treatment you can't quite figure out why
simply grab her some coloring books set
them down next to her and let her know
that she's acting like a child
because big girl words to tell you
what's really going on that's a great
idea it down there's too many guys
walking no it's true it's true what do
they say when women say what's they guys
say what's wrong we say nothing but for
whatever reason we just allow us chicks
to act like children why believing that
they've made multiple women finish on
this Earth so I just wanted to set the
record straight real fast you didn't do
it she faked she faked it yeah that gu
is going to respond to this with free
words still hit though I want to see
what you look like under the MK like why
you hiding your face so you going to
show her what's underneath I'm hiding my
face for the same reason you're wearing
makeup okay I have been red pilled when
it came to makeup I don't wear a ton I
just do like the light stuff but the
amount of chicks that come on the show
and I don't recognize them without the
makeup it's crazy Bo don't know me and I
wouldn't have done it and if you if I
don't know you then why stop interrup oh
I remember this I remember I used to
watch I never watched The Bachelor like
that closely but I used to watch Recaps
no way boy don't know me and I wouldn't
have done it and if you if I don't know
you then please stop interrupting
me the thing is when I got down on one
again I got interrupted good Lord done
with it I'd say he's done with you too
by the sounds of it and I don't don't
blame him we can all see through the
fake crocodile tears and you playing a
little victim card yeah and he was hated
after this I don't buy
it like how old are you stop crying is
Cry Me a River Cry Me a
River how many B you got on this
camp
oh down down stay down they have the
audacity to say that women and men
should be in the same Sports the
audacity so this man is putting up $1
million to bet that a High School boys
basketball team would beat a WNBA team
and I have to say this is the most
disrespectful yet truest [__] I've ever
seen no I would and I played 16 years of
basketball it's not even close if a guy
played like I played um a couple years
in college and I I play wreck with guys
sometimes and I know if they played like
over maybe a year in high school I'm not
going to win um it depends how athletic
they are like scrawnier guys I can I can
like I've beaten guys but you know any
guy with like even like half the
training you had you're
done I could beat you King yeah I could
beat you I can beat you boys beat the US
Women's Soccer Team who are meant to be
the best female soccer team in the world
at that point you who I'm betting on and
all I got to say is tell him to bring me
my
money want to break their ego next time
they try texting you good morning sorry
I fell asleep respond with it's okay I
just got
home that you'll have them chasing I
love the game I love of Hustle
Man yeah perfect hell yeah let's get it
so how long y'all been dating months do
you like him because his voice is is it
a plus it is a plus why is it cuz it's
hot have you have you ever did a phone
swap a phone swap yeah hey you want to
do s SW I got you bro let's do it let's
do it do a phone Swap come
on are you hiding something no I'm not
she's hiding something bro I know I'm
not hiding something go go on your uh go
on her snap and her
Instagram I ain't wor about your phone
I'm wearing about
hers damn no it's not too much not too
much she texting a lot of guys though n
who's that who's that oh damn it's
nobody go her dance bro oh I see that's
my best friend bro don't worry see a lot
of girls we're chilling we're chilling
see a lot of girls I see a lot of girls
bro who are they bro that's nobody there
nobody nobody hey nothing comp to her
bro nothing her he's hiding something
they're both as bad as one another but I
love the way she's trying to stick stick
it on him at the end like she weren't
trying to delete [__] at the beginning
and she'll probably try and make him
feel bad for the whole night saying who
are those girls who are those girls and
not mention the fact that she deleted a
conversation herself two months in and
it's not looking too good is it yeah
this might not go well looking good bre
it's not looking
good she she want me she want me y'all
tell me why this dude told me to meet
him at oaka is at 6 and so like 6:10 I'm
like I'm on my way but he never text
back and I get here he's nowhere to be
found it's
650 40 minutes late on the first date
you're already not respecting his time
he probably thought you know
what I'm done no look go on your home
screen real quick N Turn it's actually
so crazy to me how rude people were
raised like I don't understand why girls
are showing up like 30 20 like I I heard
that girls are always late for dates and
I'm like who who raised you the first
time you're meeting someone
really who
that a boyfriend you're for the streets
to take the grand with a boyfriend that
is bad all right darl stay loyal next
time you married yes you're cheting on
your Hub yeah Vegas it's Vegas baby oh
no oh hey I know him we did a collab a
while ago
we're both married are you cheating on
your husband in Vegas absolutely not
just her
maybe is she she's cheating on her
husband in Vegas wow fact how many times
you cheating on your husband you right
now yeah you are kind of hot who are you
you got a ring on your finger though I
know I wonder if they have kids he did
good look who wants to me with no money
no nobody find a me money anybody knows
these women then please send this to
their husband yes on this on this she
cheats she belongs to the streets you
know and I think I actually think
there's going to be a trend where women
really can't get away with stuff the way
they used to because the internet I mean
the world is small guys the world is
small you don't know who knows who but
you know let me know what you guys think
in the comments really all of these
things just show the general Trend and
direction of our society if we don't do
something or figure out a way to
navigate forward I don't see it going
the other way but let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel get yourself a women sh of both
t-shirt I'll talk to you next time